we're told that the measure of angle qpr
so qpr so that's this angle right over
here is 2x plus 122. and i'll assume
that these are in degrees so it's 2x
plus 122
degrees and the measure of angle rps
rps so that's this angle right over here
is 2x plus 22 degrees and they ask us to
find the measure of angle rps so we need
to figure out this right over here
so we would be able to figure that out
if we just knew what x is and lucky for
us we can use the information given to
solve for x and then figure out what 2
times x plus 22 is and the main big idea
here the thing that pops out here is
that the outside rays for both of these
angle form a line these two angles form
a line you could you could say that they
are supplementary these are both of
these angles are supplementary 2x plus
22 plus another 2x plus 122 is going to
add up to 180. we know that this isn't
this entire angle right over here
is 180 degrees so we can say that the
measure of angle qpr this angle right
over here 2x
plus 1 22
plus the green angle plus our
angle rps so plus
2x plus 22 is going to be equal to 180
degrees is going to be equal to 180
and now we can add
we can start simplifying this we have
two x's we have another two x's so those
are going to add up to be 4x and then we
have 122
plus 22 so that's going to be 144 and
that's the sum of those two are going to
be equal to 180 degrees we can subtract
144 from both sides
subtract 144 from both sides on the left
hand side we're just going to be left
with a
4x this 4x right here and on the right
hand side we're going to have let's see
if we were subtracting 140 we would have
40 left and then we have to subtract
another 4 so it's going to be 36 divide
both sides by 4 and we get
x is equal to
9. now remember we're not done yet they
didn't say solve for x they said find
the measure of angle rps which is 2
times x plus 22 or 2 times
9 plus 22 which is 18 plus 22 which is
equal to 40. so the measure of angle rps
is 40 degrees